We will launch the Android Jetpack,
This is our next generation of components and tools.
And an architecture guide to help you speed up
Your Android development.
You tell us that it is difficult to be backward compatible,
So we built a support library.
You tell us that it's difficult to manage your application due to data changes.
So we built the architecture components.
We hear that you want more, so we are building more.
Android architecture components provide us with
A template to write production-ready Android code,
This can help us add new developers faster.
The Jetpack consists of four parts:
Foundation, architecture, behavior and UI.
Each component can be used and built separately.
To maintain backward compatibility.
The Android architecture components are very modular.
So we can choose the feature set we want that applies to our application.
Conscious observers and observable components of the life cycle
Allow separation of concerns to create testable,
Reliable, high quality applications.
One of the most important things we don't have to worry about is
Which code to go to.
This helps us test some models. It helps us build reliable code.
We don't have to have life cycle awareness,
Just help new developers join,
Then write the appropriate modular production-ready code,
There is no need to add all of these extra different themes.
It also utilizes the Kotlin language feature.
Make your work more efficient.
Jetpack management
Trivial activities such as persistence, background tasks, navigation and lifecycle management.
So you can cancel the boilerplate code and focus on what makes your app great.
Database persistence has been a nightmare for the Android community for years, and Room is a huge improvement.
The creation of the Room is due to the testability,
So we can be on the persistence layer
Add test coverage that we were unable to add before.
There is no need to build any infrastructure around it.
With Android Jetpack, we eliminated all types of problems.
And make the code easier to maintain.
Since Zillow has been using Android architecture components,
So the user encounters fewer errors in the application.
We will continue to add new features to Jetpack across the Android platform.
It's easy to get started.
You can update your app at your own pace.
And all these components
Both can be run on older versions of the platform.
to know more information
And start with developer.android.com/jetpack!